thank you
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slum net from Norway are
establishing a mission a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the world even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you even
[Applause]
how are you guys doing
many of you would have already known the
story of this Swedish Quran bunny the
Scandinavian Quran burner there's many
Quran burners that we deal with on this
channel who has you know stood outside
of the Turkish Embassy and burned a copy
of the Quran with the permission of
course of the Swedish government and my
colleagues zeeshan's Malta Jannah has
covered this angle from a political
perspective talking about the
hypocrisies of some of these European
nations which many of which they ban the
burning of flags for example the
European Union flag the French flag in
the case of France and so on
so you can go ahead and watch those
videos I'm not going to be doing that in
this video I'm going to be taking aim
directly at you
Rasmussen is that his name Rasmussen
let's just say whatever the hell your
name is because I don't care what your
name is I don't need to know what your
name is you need to know what my name is
because the truth of the matter is
Rasmussen or whatever how the hell your
name is yes
I would be ashamed of myself to
deprecate myself in such a manner that I
wouldn't even be able to challenge the
Muslim communities that you saw
vehemently hate I mean if you hate the
Muslim Community and you hate Islam then
why don't you challenge their ideas that
is because you know deep down in your
fragile little soul that you have and
that P brain that you got on your head
that you are no match for members of the
Muslim Community either conversationally
or physically
many people have said to me why don't
you go ahead and challenge this Quran
bana for a debate I think this is an
insult to me
this is an insult to me because the kind
of thing I'd be challenging him to is
the following I'd be saying this
I'd be saying let's go ahead and go to a
public area yes
why why are you going to go to a public
area I'll tell you why I will hand him a
cloth I will wear black shoes what are
you talking about here please I will
tell you what I'm going to be doing I'm
going to be wearing black shoes shiny
black shoes
and then I'm going to close my eyes
and this Rasmussen is going to shine my
shoes until they become sparkling
so that when I open my eyes again and I
look it down at the shoe I see the
reflection of the champ staring back at
me and Rasmussen is looking down at the
shoe at the same time seeing his
ineptitude and ineffectuality and
impotence being
you know my servant because the truth of
the matter is Rasmussen you're going to
become my servant and the servant of the
Muslim Community today how so
how so I tell you how well did you not
know that we are building
or we're helping with the building and
the refurbishing and the expanding and
have been doing so of the biggest
Scandinavian dawa project
in Scandinavia it is the biggest mosque
in Tower Center in the whole of
Scandinavia you might have seen some of
the adverts because I know you're a
secret admirer of the champ
yes you're looking at the champ of
course you don't challenge the champ you
don't challenge anybody in the Muslim
Community because I'll tell you why you
won't challenge me because the moment
Ali or any of those names come into your
mind what happens is that some
involuntary excrement comes out of your
orifice say that one again for me
brother I say that some involuntary
excrement comes out of your orifice to
the point where you can't control
yourself and maybe your bowels are
bursting you need to use the toilet
so that when you go to the toilet and
you come out and your mom is there to
see you
and even she hates what she sees
even she hates that face
she hates you because how could she not
hate you you are a failure of a human
being you are a failure of a human being
that's why you won't challenge the
Muslim communities or members thereof
conversationally or physically you or
any of your Associates because the thing
is I would feel ashamed I'd feel
cowardly
I feel like a downright dastardly coward
if I hated the community so much but
couldn't find the testicular fortitude
maybe because of a lacking of such a
thing
to challenge the very community that I
hate
I would hate that I would hate to to
hate a community but I can't even
challenge these people you all you can
do is burn I mean anyone can burn a book
I can get a small child to burn a book
this is not a demonstration of freedom
of speech and bravery and Gallant
courageousness
this is just a demonstration of an
inability to engage so I'm going to do
now is I'm going to use you for the
service of the Muslim Community
the people last time there was a Quran
burner in Norway he helped us raise
almost 300 000 dollars
now you are going to be the servant of
the Muslim Community
and help us raise the money again
because we are you are helping us grow
the Muslim Community yes you are going
to help us as a servant that you are the
people now the Muslim people the anger
than him the the passionate and
infuriated Muslim people with the fact
that you decided to take aim at them in
this way we don't need to make
intellectual arguments what we're going
to do is make a change because us as the
Muslim Community we're not going to say
idly by while people are disrespecting
our religion we're going to make exactly
that very thing the religion of Islam in
the area that you reside in and live in
more prominent and we're going to
educate the likes of you and your
Associates and the community at large of
Islam so I'm now I'm done with you my
servant I'm done with you boy I don't
need you anymore Rasmussen whatever your
name is we don't need you anymore
now I'm going to speak to the Muslim
people now we instead of being angry and
writing hate comments and doing this we
have a way of making a change
or is it that you just want to or we
just want to speak and we just want to
get angry but our money is not where our
mouth is
our money is not where our mouth is what
we need to do right now is there's a
link below and this is the biggest
Scandinavian Tower project I have gone
and visited it myself many times and I'm
going again to see the Expansion Project
I've seen this send me updates all the
time to see where the money is going
these people I can vouch for them
I will say that go ahead and click the
link below and when you click the link
below put as much the biggest possible
donation to prepare yourself spiritually
and financially for Ramadan as you
possibly can
the Allah I was going to say the prophet
said but I can start by saying Allah
whenever he talks about struggling
in his sake
11 times in the Quran he starts by
talking about doing so with your money
first
with your money first
and the prophet Muhammad told us
that money does not depreciate by giving
this is a Masjid so I'm saying to you
now it's a Masjid and dawah Center so
that people like this fool this
ignoramus
this ignoramus
this diminished individual
who
needs to come and Sparkle my shoes
yes he needs to clean it up and shine it
real diligently
okay that guy and other people like him
can understand the message of Islam now
that's the final thing I'm going to say
here
and this is your opportunity and there
are many things and did you know one
verse of the Quran I want to leave you
with is a beautiful verse in Surah Allah
says
that this non-equivalent are those who
give in the Charity's sake before the
conquest yes you don't like these words
I know this guy yes doesn't like this
word Conquest
and the and the fighting yes those are
higher in rank than the ones who give
after meaning what now I'm saying that
this is our opportunity to be Minnesota
the ones who give first because I
believe you me
the face
of Europe is going to change
demographically and these people are
dying in their rage and they're burning
books and they can't handle it because
of their fragile Egos and we need to
make a change now these are really the
only platforms where we can do this so
let's take this opportunity seriously
let's see how the Muslims show the
Muslim Community can respond in a strong
way and in a financial way
wasallam told us whoever builds a mosque
for Allah Allah will build for him a
similar house in Jannah
and we know the great reward that will
not only be gained but rather will fill
your grave after your death whenever
someone prays there whenever someone
gives shahada in the Masjid whenever
someone learns something in the Masjid
yes that will be something that you'll
have on your scale